I cannot wait to see you okay see you
soon bye hey do you want to go to
Lauren's party with me on Saturday oh I
just made plans with your mom
no one's like my status yet will you
like it yeah thanks it's not funny
though hey I'm using your curling irons
freezing it is so hot are you kidding me
it's freezing do you want to come to San
Diego with my whole family like at the
end of the month visit uncle job yeah
this is u2 he was talking about you okay
this is for you happy birthday be an
ally we love you your dad just like 14
at my facebook statuses okay I'm up are
you up so early it's not early it's
10:00 really I'm just coming to get that
red shirt we're going why are you making
me go to brunch before noon people go to
brunch at 10:00 nobody goes to brunch at
10:00 a.m. easy your bronzer hey I'm
using your deodorant you look really
good in this picture thank you did you
borrow my shirt yeah I came over to get
it last week with a spare key I'll say
your mom looks amazing but he said well
what are you doing tonight instead oh
that's great and I said I don't know I
don't know any plans I'm currently
laying in my bed it's spooning a bag of
chips
wait did you already send that you have
to run all your texts by me before you
press send are you doing
oh we're gonna be very straight go
straight
good what do you go straight he wanted
to go on a date with you I think you
would know but that's it if he wanted to
go today with me he would going to do
with me
you're like giving him too much of what
he wants you keep texting him you have
to do what I do just be like hey and
then they respond and then you don't
answer for life
six days hey I'm using your toothbrush
you're beautiful
maybe you're beautiful
I miss your mom you ever think about
when we grow older how we should get
houses next to each other and you know
have kids make any best friends yes
except in my fantasy they grow up and
they fall in love and they get married
and then we get to be like in-laws oh my
god and then they can have kids and then
you and I can be like the best grandma
the coolest grandmas